Taiwans Präsidentin mitten im Getümmel
des Wahlkampfes neugierig auf zwei in
well sind auch der deutsche
Schriftsteller Stefan Thome und seine
Frau
die Präsidentin trommelt im
regionalwahlkampf für Kandidaten ihrer
Partei seit fast 30 Jahren wählen die
Taiwaner ihre Regierung selbst doch mit
dieser Eigenständigkeit hat ihr großer
Nachbar China ein Problem
Kunst bringt noch viele
Herausforderungen aber wenn wir Taiwaner
weiter zusammenhalten können wir sie
überwinden
je länger Taiwan seinen eigenen Weg geht
desto weniger Gemeinsamkeiten gibt es
wenn man die Menschen hier fragt was
unterscheidet sie denn von China dann
werden sehr sehr viele Leute sagen naja
bei uns gibt es eben nicht Demokratie
und wir haben uns zerstritten und wir
haben uns erkämpft die wurde ihnen ja
nicht geschenkt oh mein Gott
wir können selbst entscheiden was für
ein Leben wir führen wollen was für eine
Gesellschaft und was für ein Land wir
sein wollen das ist nicht
selbstverständlich
mit so einem durchgedrehten und
böswilligen Nachbarn zu tun
gemeint ist die Volksrepublik Chinas
Staats- und Parteichef shising Ping
bekräftigt seine Drohungen gegen Taiwan
wir werden niemals Versprechen auf
Gewaltanwendung zu verzichten wir
behalten uns das Recht vor alle nötigen
Mittel einzusetzen
immer mehr Aufrüstung Propaganda
Militärmanöver China rasselt mit den
Säbeln droht Taiwan mit einem angreif
mit welchem Selbstbewusstsein begegnen
die Menschen dieser Bedrohung der
Schriftsteller Stefan Thome bringt
deutschen Lesern Taiwan
Selbstverständnis näher vieles habe
chinesische Wurzeln aber entscheidend
sei der Wechsel von Fremdherrschaften
gewesen das von außen kommende Mächte
den Menschen hier eine Identität
aufzwingen wollten also aus dem
Widerstand dagegen ist dieses
Zusammengehörigkeitsgefühl entstand und
ist ein Bewusstsein entstanden dass es
ein besonderer Ort ist in dem Leute
etwas miteinander verbinden das hier
kostet 80 ja
er spricht ihre Sprache und er weiß dass
man die Geschichte ihrer Insel kennen
muss um zu verstehen was Ihnen wichtig
ist hast ich bin relativ junger Zeit das
ist möglich so eine taiwanische
Identität zu vertreten sagen ich bin
nicht Chinese und ich bin auch nicht
Japaner sondern ich bin in Taiwan
geboren und in Taiwan aufgewachsen das
ist meine Heimat und diese Radikalität
der Wechselfeld Umbrüche gibt es in
jedem Land aber in solcher Radikalität
wie hier in Taiwan glaube ich nur sehr
sehr wenig
wie gehen taiwanische Kultur schaffen
der mit der Situation um die komplexe
Geschichte seines Landes ist immer
wieder Thema für wavit Chang einen der
bekanntesten Filmemacher Taiwans vor
allem die japanische Kolonialzeit hat es
ihm angetan sie dauerte 50 Jahre bis zum
Ende des Zweiten Weltkriegs und prägt
Taiwan bis heute gönnen
ich möchte mit Geschichten über unsere
eigene Heimat und Kultur erreichen dass
noch mehr Leute Taiwan kennenlernen
seine Ursprünge und seine Gegenwart
und damit wir dann sogar von hier aus
entscheiden können in welche Richtung
wir in Zukunft gehen
die Ursprünge des modernen Taiwan
reichen 400 Jahre zurück Niederländer
hatten Teile der Insel besetzt ein
chinesischer Feldherr vertrieb sie diese
entscheidende Epoche will way als großen
Animationsfilm in die Kinos bringen
wichtig ist ihm dabei die Perspektive
der indigenen Bevölkerung die
ursprünglichen Taiwaner wurden von immer
neuen Herrschern unterdrückt
taiwanskultur kommt von den indigenen
von Einwanderern aus China und von
anderen Einwanderern alles zusammen
macht sie so vielfältig
taiwan ist klein aber es vereint die
ganze Welt in sich das macht es so
besonders
das bisher letzte Kapitel in Taiwans
Fremdbestimmung begann als Chinas
Bürgerkrieg endete Maus Kommunisten
hatten gesiegt ihr Gegner Gian Kai Check
Flo mit seiner nationalchinesen auf die
Insel die gerade noch japanisch
beherrschten Taiwaner ließ er zu
vorzeigechinesen umerziehen eine eigene
Identität war streng verboten
[Musik]
das betraf auch die die überhaupt gar
keine chinesischen Wurzeln hatten
Taiwans indigene Minderheiten nur an der
Ostküste und anderen entlegenen Orten
konnten sie ihre eigenen Traditionen
erhalten
Stefan Thome trifft einen Schriftsteller
Kollegen Charly lang schreibt über das
Leben in den Bergen und über die
Wohnungen seine Volksgruppe viele Dörfer
hier bluten aus junge Menschen ziehen
zur Arbeit in die Städte zurückbleiben
alte und kleine Kinder
Besuch beim letzten Korbflechter des
Dorfes
wie viel Kilo kann man damit tragen 100
kg
findet hier nur wenige
Arbeitsmöglichkeiten
um so ein altes Handwerk zu betreiben
braucht man dann noch eine andere
Einkommensquelle
ein altes Haus in seinem Heimatdorf hat
Charlie lang zum Kulturzentrum umgebaut
erst mit 20 begann er sich für die
eigene Kultur zu interessieren heute
schreibt er Gedichte Reportagen und
Wörterbücher mal auf Chinesisch mal in
der bunonsprache
die Denkweise ist nicht gleich auf
Chinesisch schreibe ich damit noch mehr
Leute unsere Probleme verstehen mit der
Stammessprache will ich unsere eigenen
Geschichten bewahren
die indigenen wurden immer wieder für
verschiedene Zwecke ausgenutzt vielen
dienen sie vor allem als Beweis dass
Taiwan eben nicht nur chinesisch ist an
diesem Hügel hatten Japaner Charlie
langs Vorfahren zu Soldaten ausgebildet
heute hat die Stellung der indigenen
sich verbessert China würde wohl auch
hier die Zeit zurückdrehen
sie würden alle indigenengruppen wieder
in einen Topf werfen das ist für uns
eine furchterregende Vorstellung
in Taiwan werde ich heute wenigstens als
bon anerkannt
Sie diese Wohnung zu lernen Taiwaner zu
sein bedeutet mit vielen Identitäten zu
leben und daraus das Beste zu machen die
Kulturschaffenden in Taiwan sagen zum
größten Teil wir haben keinen Einfluss
darauf was die Regierung in Peking
entscheidet ob es zum Krieg kommt ob
sich die Krise zuspitzt oder nicht
unsere Aufgabe ist hier wir wollen
unsere Gesellschaft weiter vorantreiben
wir wollen diese Öffnung das was wir
erreicht haben in den letzten
Jahrzehnten das wollen wir weiterführen
und da gibt es eine große Aufgabe für
die Leute die schreiben Filme machen
Musik machen und so weiter alle die
Kultur erschaffen in Taiwan wollen dazu
beitragen
die Zeit der Fremdbestimmung ist vorbei
und wenn es nach den Menschen in Taiwan
geht soll das auch so bleiben